hi this is presh talwalkar
today's puzzle is something you might
see on a technical interview question
imagine you have three people and 11
identical coins
how many ways are there to split 11
coins to three people
only the total number of coins to each
person matters so you might give five
coins to blue six coins to red and no
coins to green
part two of the question
how many ways are there if each person
has to get at least one coin
now five six zero would not be a
solution because we have to give green
at least one coin so might give green
one red five and blue five
give these problems a try and when
you're ready keep watching the video for
the solutions
we'll start out by solving the number of
ways you can split 11 coins to three
people
we'll use a trick which is to place two
dividers between the coins
we'll color one divider blue and another
divider red
the number of coins to the left of the
blue divider will be the number of coins
that blue gets the number of coins
between the dividers will be the number
of coins that red gets and the number of
coins to the right of the red divider
will be the number of coin that greens
gets
so if i place the dividers in the
following positions
there are three coins to the left of the
blue divider that go to blue
there are six coins in between the
divider that's how many red gets and
they're two coins to the right of the
red divider which go to green
we can change the positions of these
dividers
if i move the blue divider over
now blue's getting five coins red is
getting four coins and green is getting
two coins
i can change the positions again if i
move the blue divider all the way over
to the left now there are no coins to
the left of the blue divider so blue is
getting zero coins in between the
dividers is seven coins that go to red
and to the right of the red divider is
four coins that go to green
imagine i shift the dividers over like
this
now blue is getting six coins
the two dividers are next to each other
there are no coins so that means red
gets no coins and green gets the
remaining five coins
i'll let you figure out how to have a
division where green gets zero coins
but basically we can count the number of
ways to split 11 coins to three
identical people by figuring out the
number of ways we can place these two
dividers
so imagine we have 11 plus two which is
13 total slots
we're going to place the dividers in two
of these slots and the coins in the
remaining slots
so we want to pick two of the spots for
the dividers
and then we place the remaining
slots we fill them with the coins
so we can count the number of ways to
split 11 coins to three people by
counting the number of ways that we can
pick the two dividers in 13 slots
that's the number of ways you can choose
two elements from 13 which is a binomial
coefficient 13 choose 2 which ends up
being 78 so that's part one answer is
that you can have 78 ways to split 11
coins three people
let's generalize this
let's assume we have n identical items
that we want to divide to our people
as we did before we basically want to
use r minus 1 dividers
we're going to need to draw out n plus r
minus 1 slots of which we're going to
pick r minus 1 dividers
so it's the number of ways that we can
choose r minus 1 elements from
n plus r minus 1
which will be n plus r minus 1 choose r
minus 1 which is equivalently n plus r
minus 1 choose n
there's another way you can think about
the solution
imagine the algebraic equation x1 plus
x2 all the way up to xr
are variables being equal to n and we
want to find the number of non-negative
integer solutions
this is exactly partitioning n into r
different spaces
so this also gives you the amount of
distinct non-negative integer solutions
to this equation you can interpret each
term x i is the amount that person i
gets
so now let's proceed to the next
question which is to do the same split
except each person has to get at least
one coin
now we don't actually have to start over
what we're going to do is a trick where
we start out by giving one coin to each
person so now we know each person has at
least one coins
now we want to divide up the remaining
eight coins
to the three people and we can do that
by dividing the eight coins using our
two divider method
so we want to divide
in the same exact way but we're just
going to add
i'll just do one example to show you how
this works imagine i put the dividers
here there's one coin to the left of the
blue divider but blue already has one
coin so blue ends up with two coins
now in between the divider
there are six coins but then we're going
to add the one that red already has
to the right of the red divider dividers
one coin we add on the one that green
already has to get two
so we can find all ways to split 11
coins three people where each person
gets at least one
by giving each person one coin and then
using our two divider method on the
eight coins remaining
so let's go through this solution
we start out by giving one coin to each
so that means they're 11 minus three
which is eight coins
we then
have to solve the problem of dividing
those eight coins into three people
so we're going to have eight plus two
which is ten slots of which we're going
to pick the two spots for the divisors
the dividers
as we just solved this will be the
number of ways to choose two elements
from 10 which is 10 choose 2
which becomes 45.
we can generalize this
let's imagine we want to split n
identical coins to our people so that
each person gets at least one coin
we start out by giving one coin to each
of the r people so they're n minus our
coins remaining
then we want to divide the n minus our
coins to our people
we've already solved this before you use
r minus one divisors for a total of n
minus 1 spots
so this becomes the number of ways to
choose r minus 1 elements from n minus 1
which is n minus 1 choose r minus 1.
algebraically if you have the solution
x1 plus x2 all the way up to xr equaling
xn equaling n
we now can solve for the number of
positive integer solutions using n minus
1 choose r minus one and in this case we
again interpret x i as the amount that
person i gets
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math and game theory you can catch me on
my blog mind your decisions which you
can follow on facebook google plus and
patreon you can catch me on social media
at preshtalwalker and if you like this
video please check out my books there
are links in the video description